[Music]
the songs are well rehearsed
the hamilton's bone silver band is ready
to go on the march
[Music]
eighteen-year-old lucy bingham grew up
here in a protestant family
[Music]
all the band members are protestants and
by tradition they see themselves as
british but in this particular area
they're in the minority
the townspeople all around are mostly
catholic and irish nationalists
and ever since brexit tensions have been
rising again
you know there's a very much division in
the community
you know we're surrounded here by
there is nationalist areas and it's like
you wouldn't go to them places because
of the past because of the troubles
people around here are very
angry
we're just heading back
to that place that dark place
and obviously we don't want to go back
at times protestants here have felt
discriminated against at one point her
own family was a target of ira assassins
lucy says
now she feels as if they have to put
their guard up all over again
she's certain she wants to stay in the
united kingdom what we've got out of
brexit it's yeah it's very much heading
for united ireland
which is against what every unionist
wants we don't want that
lucy's home in northern ireland lies
just a few kilometers from the border to
the republic of ireland but she hardly
ever goes there
cross mcglenn is a catholic town a
former stronghold of the ira
right next to the big former army base
is the youth center the catholic youth
here define their identities very
differently they cross the border
routinely they all have relatives in the
republic of ireland
an irish man
yeah i just i wouldn't really count
myself as british because we are still
connected to ireland
and we live in northern ireland we're
still ireland so irish yeah
i feel like
even though northern ireland is part of
the united kingdom i just feel because
it's just our own island
you just feel irish
all at once unification with eu member
republic of ireland is on the table
according to surveys the irish
nationalist shin fein once the political
arm of the ira
emerged from the northern ireland
assembly election in may as the
strongest party liz kimmins is a deputy
to the assembly
kovid and brexit has shown people that
there are huge benefits at looking at an
all island economy and an all island
approach and and that's something that's
grown without any of us pushing and it's
coming naturally and certainly we will
be doing all we can to facilitate that
but the violence of the past still
haunts the present day memorials to
fighters killed on both sides are well
maintained
liz kimmins shin fein insists that it's
changed it has long been committed to
achieving its goal of a united ireland
using only peaceful means
one of us want to live in a society that
is peaceful and that is prosperous
and that's something that we all have
have common ground on and for those
people that do fear the the prospect of
constitutional change i would be saying
then there's nothing to fear be part of
the discussion that is how we're going
to shape it that is how we address those
fears
but it's going to take some very tactful
and persuasive diplomacy and lots of
patience to bring loyalist protestants
like lucy on board
well i hope in my future in my life that
i never see a united ireland
i hope that i i live to the day where
it's still northern ireland
very much that's part of the uk
most if not all the hamilton's bone
silver band members think like lucy
but many also sense that the winds are
changing
maybe not today maybe not tomorrow but
someday soon
[Music]